لا تحتاج الدول الى تنظيم مظاهرات شعبيه
ترفع فيها الوف الاعلام لتؤكد سيادتها على
جزء من البلاد الواقعه تحت سلطتها الا اذا
كانت هذه السياده محل شك في الاصل حتى من
مدعيها انفسهم او هي غير مشروعه في الاقل
بموجب القوانين والقرارات والاعراف
الدوليه المعاصره سيضحك العالم مل اشدقيه
او سيسخر الى حد الترحم على نعمه العقل لو
انه شاهد الفرنسيين ينظمون مسيره اعلام
سنويه ليؤكدوا ان الشانزيليزي لهم او راى
البريطانيين يخرجون الى الشوارع كل عام
ليتمسكوا بحقهم في وسط من ستاره او سمع
المصريين يعتزمون القيام بتحرك مماثل في
القاهره تعبيرا عن تمسكهم باحدى ضفتي
النيل لكن اسرائيل وربما اسرائيل وحدها في
عالم اليوم هي من تجرؤ على اقامه مهرجانات
الرقص بالاعلام في موقع جغرافي او معلم
تاريخي تزعم انها تملك حق السياده عليه
بعدما احتلته وسيطرت عليه بالقوه منذ ما
يقارب سته عقود من الزمن هل يصدر هذا
الفعل عن شعور متزايد في اللاوعي
الاسرائيلي بتبدد اسطوره المرور العابر في
المكان امام حقيقه التجذر المستمر لاصحابه
الاصليين في تربته ام تراها غطرسه القوه
يستمر اصحابها قلب الحق باطلا والباطل حقا
في عالم يضع الدوله اليهوديه كما تصف
نفسها فوق القانون الدولي ويجعل التمديد
بادعاءاتها جرما قد يودي بصاحبه الى
المحاكم بتهمه العداء للساميه تنطلق مسيره
الاعلام السياسيا من الزعم بان القدس
بشطرها الغربي والشرقي هي العاصمه الابديه
لاسرائيل غير ان المشاركين فيها من
مستوطنين وبرلمانيين ووزراء متطرفين
يتحركون جغرافيا وسط شوارع وازقه محاطه
ببيوت سكنيه ومحلات تجاريه ومساجد اسلاميه
وكنائس مسيحيه عمرها الفلسطينيون ويواصلون
صنع الحياه فيها منذ الوف السنين دونما
انقطاع اما الذي قد يكون اعجب غرائب القصه
فهو ان هؤلاء المنحدرين اصلا من اقوام
واعراق وبلدان شتى وفيهم الابيض والاسود
والاصفر والبين بينبين يزعمون جميعا بان
لهم اسلافا عاشوا هنا قبل ثلاثه الاف سنه
فيتفهم المجتمع الدولي ما يقولون او يصمت
ويلقي الى خزائن الارشيف بقوانينه
المعاصره وقراراته التي تنص على ان القدس
ارض فلسطينيه محتله ولها اصحابها الذين
ينب ان تكون تحت سيادتهم ثم يتحول ان وقع
الصدام بين الجانبين الى مطالبتهما بضبط
النفس وانصدام بين الجانبين سبق ان اندلع
على اشده حين اطلق الفلسطينيون في العام
تحذيرات من مرور مسيره الاعلام
الاسرائيليه في احياء البلده القديمه من
القدس المحتله باعتبار ذلك خطا احمر
سيتصدون له بكل استطاعتهم
انذاك اشتعلت مواجهه عسكريه بين قوى
المقاومه في قطاع غزه وجيش الاحتلال
استمرت 11 يوما واتحدى الفلسطينيون خلالها
كما لم يتحدوا من قبل ليسجلوا صفافهم
جميعا على كامل مساحه فلسطين التاريخيه في
معركه التصدي لاجراءات سلبي وطنهم وتهويد
مقدساتهم
انها برميل وبارود يتدحرج في شوارع القدس
قالت وكالات انباء في وصف مسيره الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ولم يكن مستغربا والحال هذه
ان تستبقها سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
باعتقال عشرات الفلسطينيين في القدس ومدن
الضفه الغربيه كما لم يكن مستغربا في ظل
حكومه اليمين الاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ دوله
الاحتلال ان تعلن الشرطه استنفار ثلاثه
الاف ومئتي رجل امن لحمايه المستوطنين
الذين هددوا مسبقا باقتحام المسجد الاقصى
واعلنوا مبكرا شعارات ابرزها الموت للعرب
يدرك الفلسطينيون بالطبع انهم لا يملكون
قوه عسكريه او سياسيه تؤهلهم لمنع مسيره
الاعلام الاسرائيليه من المرور في شوارع
القدس العتيقه ولكن تجربتهم التاريخيه في
مقاومه الاحتلال اهلتهم على مدى 75 سنه
مضت منذ بدء النك به ليجدوا الوسائل
الكفيله بحسم الجواب البديهي على سؤال
السياده الشارك علم واحد مرفوع على ساعد
فتى مقدسي قد يكفي لافشال الهدف من رفع
الوف الاعلام المحميه بالمدافى